This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Detroit, Michigan is the home to the Ambassador Bridge, which links Detroit to the Canadian border city of Windsor. The ambassador is essential. CNN once called it the most economically important one and a half miles of roadway in the Western Hemisphere. Every day, endless lines of trucks
这里是《99%无形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。密歇根州底特律是大使桥的所在地，这座桥连接着底特律与加拿大边境城市温莎。大使桥至关重要。美国有线电视新闻网曾称它是西半球经济上最重要的的一点五英里道路。每天，无休止的卡车长龙
wait for hours on a concrete plaza flanked by rows of traffic cones so they can be processed by a border agent. That's producer, Andrew Laypen. The ambassador is the linchpin of the North American auto industry. Cars are constantly being driven back and forth to different factories. Last year, more than 2 million trucks drove across the ambassador. In fact, 30% of all trade between the U.S. and Canada rolls over this bridge. Everybody has to use the bridge because they basically don't have any other choice.
在夹在数排交通锥中间的混凝土广场上等待数小时，以便接受边境官员的查验。那是制作人安德鲁·莱平。大使桥是北美汽车行业的支柱。汽车不断地在不同工厂之间被开来开去。去年，有超过200万辆卡车驶过大使桥。事实上，美国和加拿大之间30%的贸易都是通过这座桥进行的。每个人都必须使用这座桥，因为他们基本上别无选择。
there's a tunnel nearby that's too small for most trucks to drive through, and the next closest international bridge is some 65 miles away. To get to the bridge, all those freight trucks first have to drive by a residential neighborhood in southwest Detroit, called Mexican Town. And for many years, they had to drive right through it. Mexican Town is right at the bridge's entry point, and residents have suffered through loud honking and negative health effects for decades. Here's how Sam Butler, president of a local neighborhood group, described it to me.
附近有一条隧道，但对大多数卡车来说太小而无法通行，而最近的下一个国际桥梁则远在约65英里之外。要到达这座桥，所有这些货车首先必须开过底特律西南部一个名为“墨西哥城”的居民区。多年来，他们不得不直接穿过该社区。墨西哥城就位于大桥的入口处，几十年来，居民们饱受刺耳的鸣笛声和对其健康的负面影响之苦。当地一个社区组织的负责人萨姆·巴特勒是这样向我描述的。
There is this black soot on windows or on the outside of people's homes that face the bridge, that you can literally take your finger, wipe off a piece of this black soot, living so close to a international crossing that gets 10,000 trucks per day. Folks in Windsor don't like the bridge either. It's not well-maintained. Large chunks of concrete have been known to break off and fall. on the streets below. Basically, everyone in the surrounding area hates this bridge, but they have nobody to complain to.
窗户上或者面向桥梁的人们房屋的外墙上有一层黑烟灰，你真的可以用手指擦掉一小块这种黑烟灰，因为住在距离每天有1万辆卡车的国际过境点这么近的地方。温莎的人们也不喜欢这座桥。它没有得到很好的维护。众所周知，大块的混凝土会断裂并掉落到下面的街道上。基本上，周边地区的每个人都讨厌这座桥，但他们无处投诉。
They can't petition the city or the county or even the U.S. or Canadian governments because none of them own this bridge. In fact, for the longest time, the Ambassador Bridge was owned by one guy. You had to take it up with him if you could get a hold of him. I'm a quiet private man, but somebody decided. to make me something other than being private. I didn't. That's Manuel Maroon.
他们不能向市政府、县政府甚至美国或加拿大政府请愿，因为这些机构都不拥有这座桥。事实上，在很长一段时间里，大使桥属于一个人。如果你能联系到他的话，你只能去找他谈。我是一个安静低调的人，但有人决定把我变成一个不再低调的人。我可没有。那是曼努埃尔·马龙。
He went by Maddie. He owned the Ambassador Bridge from 1979 until 2018 when the ownership transferred to his son, Matthew. The elder Maroon may have been private in the sense that he almost never gave interviews. But for decades, he was, quietly, one of the most important people in Detroit. When Maddie Maroon died in 2020,
他通常被称为马迪。他从1979年起拥有大使桥，直到2018年所有权转让给他的儿子马修。老马龙之所以低调，是因为他几乎从未接受过采访。但在几十年里，他悄然成为了底特律最重要的人物之一。当马迪·马龙于2020年去世时，
he was a billionaire. A good chunk of his empire was funded with bridge tolls and the duty-free gas stations on the bridge. By this point, you're probably asking the obvious question. How can one man and his family own an international bridge? A critical piece of infrastructure that so many people have to use. Actually, a lot of critical infrastructure is privately owned. And the story of the Maroon family and Detroit shows how this kind of relationship can go totally wrong. The Ambassador Bridge has always been privately owned, and when it was built in the 1920s, that wasn't so unusual.
他已是一位亿万富翁。他的商业帝国很大一部分是由过桥费和桥上的免税加油站资助的。听到这里，你可能会问一个显而易见的问题：一个人和他的家族怎么能拥有一座国际桥梁？这是一座有这么多人必须使用的关键基础设施。事实上，许多关键基础设施都是私有化的。马龙家族和底特律的故事表明，这种关系可能会彻底走向错误。大使桥一直都是私有的，在20世纪20年代建造时，这并不那么罕见。
At the time, the economy was booming, and the country was modernizing. But local governments were often slow to act. So big infrastructure projects, like bridges, sometimes needed private investors to get off the ground. In Detroit, the auto industry was taking off, but there was no easy way to get parts across the river from Kansas. Canada. They needed a bridge. The city and the state weren't building one, so private investors started raising money and drawing up plans. I should add, the mayor of Detroit at the time did not like the idea that this bridge would be privately owned. He tried to stop it. But after the city passed a ballot proposal by a huge margin, he had no choice. The stakes were driven into
当时，经济正在蓬勃发展，国家也在现代化。但地方政府的行动往往迟缓。因此，像桥梁这样的大型基础设施项目有时需要私人投资者来启动。在底特律，汽车工业正在腾飞，但没有简单的方法将零件从堪萨斯州运过河。加拿大。他们需要一座桥。由于城市和州没有建造桥梁，私人投资者开始筹集资金并制定计划。我应该补充一点，当时的底特律市长不喜欢这座桥将由私人拥有的想法。他试图阻止它。但在该市以压倒性优势通过一项投票提案后，他别无选择。桩子被打入
the ground in 1927. At a ceremony to mark the occasion, a 16-year-old girl in high high heels, bounced across a catwalk over the Detroit River. This girl, Helen Austin, was the daughter of one of the bridge's original investors. Reports at the time said she was the first person to walk across the river. Here's what one local newspaper wrote that day. To the clouds of dark brown smoke that rose above the railroad, one could vision a mighty steel structure of greater clearance than the Brooklyn Bridge, spanning the Detroit River and opening a new era in continental transportation. But the celebrations were short-lived.
1927年的地面。在庆祝这一时刻的仪式上，一名穿着高跟鞋的16岁女孩在横跨底特律河的猫道上蹦蹦跳跳。这个名叫海伦·奥斯汀的女孩是该桥最初的投资者之一。当时的报道称她是第一个步行过河的人。当地一家报纸当天是这样写的：在铁路上方升起的团团深棕色烟雾中，人们可以想象出一个比布鲁克林大桥净空更高、跨越底特律河并开启大陆交通新纪元的宏伟钢结构。但庆祝活动是短暂的。
The ambassador struggled after the Great Depression, and for years had financial problems. The owners managed to keep it open by making the bridge into a publicly traded company with shares available on the stock market. For a time, this approach helped keep the bridge solvent. But ultimately, the decision to sell shares opened the door to a takeover by one man, a man nobody in Detroit had ever really heard of. His basic biography ought to be that of Rags to Rich's American hero, and instead he's probably the most disliked businessman in Detroit
大萧条后，大使桥举步维艰，多年来一直存在财务问题。所有者通过将该桥变成一家在股票市场上提供股票的公开上市公司，设法维持其开放。有一段时间，这种方法有助于维持该桥的偿付能力。但最终，出售股票的决定为一个人接管打开了大门，一个底特律从没真正听说过的人。他的基本生平应该是一个白手起家的美国英雄，相反，他可能是底特律几代人中最不受欢迎的商人
by far in a couple of generations. That's John Gallagher. He's a retired Detroit Free Press journalist and one of the only people to have ever interviewed Maroon, who really was a self-made success. Maroon started working in his dad's garage after college, and tenaciously grew that into a local trucking empire. Maddie told me during one of the few times when he was talking to reporters
远远超过其他人。那是约翰·加拉格尔。他是《底特律自由报》的退休记者，也是极少数采访过马龙的人之一，马龙确实是一个白手起家取得成功的人。马龙大学毕业后开始在父亲的车库里工作，并顽强地将其发展为一个地方卡车运输帝国。马迪在极少数与记者交谈的时候告诉我
that as a teenager, he had pumped gas for Jimmy Hoffa. And, you know, it came from sort of rags to riches, built this enormous fortune, mainly through his trucking company. Maddie Maroon outbid some fierce competition, including from Warren Buffett to get total ownership of the bridge. Maddie Maroon actually had a long history with the ambassador before he brought. purchased it. His family had been pushed out of their home by the original construction project. But 50 years later, the bridge was all his. Basically, a license to print money.
他在十几岁时曾为吉米·霍法加过油。而且，你知道，它有点像白手起家，建立起了这个巨大的财富，主要是通过他的卡车运输公司。马迪·马龙击败了一些激烈的竞争对手，其中包括沃伦·巴菲特，从而获得了这座桥的全部所有权。其实马迪·马龙在购买大使桥之前，就与它有着长期的渊源。他的家人曾因最初的建设工程而被赶出家园。但50年後，这座桥完全属于他了。基本上就是印钞机。
You have a family-controlled private company of scale, right, that, you know, you do the mass, but they must have been turning millions and millions of dollars of unbelievable profit from this asset. This is Steve Tobachman, a former Democratic Michigan State Representative from Southwest Detroit. He says, after Maddie Maroon bought the bridge in 1979, he became a notorious figure in the community. Describing every shenanigan Maddie Maroon got up to in Detroit would take hours.
你拥有一个规模庞大的家族控制的私营公司，对吧，你知道，你算一下账，他们一定从这项资产中获得了数百万甚至数千万令人难以置信的利润。这是史蒂夫·托巴赫曼，曾任底特律西南部的民主党密歇根州众议员。他说，马迪·马龙在1979年买下这座桥后，成了社区里臭名昭著的人物。要描述马迪·马龙在底特律搞过的所有恶作剧需要几个小时。
I'm not going to do that. But baseline, according to DeBachman, Maroon didn't do very much to address the long-standing complaints about noise and dirt in the neighborhoods near the bridge. In fact, there wasn't much community outreach at all. There was no presence for this company in the community other than the commerce they were doing. So there weren't large investments. There wasn't like there was a Manny Maroon community center or rec center or, you know, reading room at the high school or anything like that.
我不会那样做。但根据托巴赫曼的说法，马龙基本上没有采取什么措施来解决长期以来关于桥梁附近社区噪音和灰尘的投诉。事实上，根本没有什么社区外展活动。除了他们正在做的商业活动之外，这家公司在社区里没有任何存在感。所以没有大手笔的投资。没有什么曼尼·马龙社区中心或娱乐中心，或者高中阅览室之类建设。
Detroit's wealthiest businessman have tended to give a lot to local charities, especially when the city started losing people in the mid-20th century. But Maddie Maroon wasn't a big public philanthropist. He was more focused on expanding the bridge empire. In the 1980s, Maroon bought up a bunch of land near the bridge. Then he presented a plan to expand the ambassador's entryway, the opening plaza. This expansion was so the bridge could accommodate more traffic and bring in more tolls. To accomplish this, Maroon needed to buy up the land near the bridge's opening. But there was one problem.
底特律最富有的商人往往向当地慈善机构捐赠大量资金，特别是当该市在20世纪中叶开始流失人口时。但马迪·马龙并不是一个热心公益的慈善家。他更专注于扩大他的桥梁帝国。20世纪80年代，马龙买下了桥附近的一大片土地。然后他提出了一个扩大大使桥入口即开放式广场的计划。这次扩建是为了让大桥能够容纳更多的交通量并带来更多的过桥费。为了实现这一点，马龙需要买下桥头附近的土地。但有一个问题。
That land was already occupied by. a vibrant residential neighborhood. I mean, the bridge company wasn't thinking about what they were wiping out. They had tunnel vision. Bridge vision, I guess, is what it should be called. Kathy Wendler is a Detroit native. She worked for the Southwest Detroit Business Association for decades, first joining in 1981, two years after the Maroons took over the bridge.
这片土地已经被一个充满活力的住宅区占用了。我的意思是，桥梁公司根本没有考虑他们在消灭什么。他们有隧道视野。我想这应该被称为桥梁视野。凯茜·温德勒是底特律本地人。她在底特律西南部商业协会工作了几十年，最初于1981年加入，也就是马龙家族接管大桥两年后。
Her job was community development. She soon realized that meant she would have have to oppose the Maroons. It was located in a community. It was located in a place. And that place was at least as important as that bridge. Important and to its residents pretty special. Southwest Detroit was not some big industrial depot, far from it.
她的工作是社区发展。她很快意识到这意味着她将不得不反对马龙家族。它坐落在一个社区里。它坐落在一个地方。那个地方至少和那座桥一样重要。对它的居民来说非常重要且特别。底特律西南部不是什么大型工业仓库，远非如此。
This is a closely knit neighborhood. A lot of the Motor City is really spread out. Wide boulevards meant for a lot of cars. But southwest, it's dense, and it's accessible. It was walkable. You didn't have to have a car. You could get groceries. You could go to the doctor.
这是一个紧密相连的社区。底特律汽车城的许多地方其实都很分散。宽阔的大道意味着有大量的汽车。但西南部密度高且交通便利。它是适合行步的。你不需要有一辆车。你可以买杂货。你可以去看医生。
You could get dry cleaning done. It was vibrant. For the folks living here, the neighborhood felt special. And the Maroons and their ambitious plans quickly became everyone's business. Here's Sam Butler again, the head of a local neighborhood group. I don't think it's hyperbole to say that a lot of neighbors feel like the bridge company has historically been an existential threat to the neighborhood. Throughout the 80s, Maddie Maroon bought up a lot of property to expand his bridge empire. His representatives went door-to-door in the Mexican town neighborhood, purchasing one house after another and putting pressure on the residents who stayed.
你可以去干洗衣服。它充满了活力。对于住在这里的人们来说，这个社区感觉很特别。而马龙家族和他们雄心勃勃的计划迅速成为了所有人的事。再次请出当地一个社区组织的负责人萨姆·巴特勒。我认为毫不夸张地说，许多邻居都觉得桥梁公司历史上一直是这个社区的生存威胁。整个80年代，马迪·马龙买下了大量房产来扩大他的桥梁帝国。他的代表在墨西哥城社区挨家挨户地走访，一栋接一栋地买下房屋，并向留下来的居民施压。
Anthony Benevides is a southwest Detroit community activist. He says the Maroons used a tactic called Blockbuster. to buy up local real estate. Basically, they would buy up houses and depopulate the street so that eventually everyone would leave. He was strategically buying houses throughout the block
安东尼·贝内维德斯是底特律西南部的社区活动人士。他说马龙家族使用了一种叫做“区块破裂”的战术来收购当地的房产。基本上，他们会买下房屋并让这条街人口减少，这样最终每个人都会离开。他有策略地买下整个街区的房屋
and just letting him sit there. They were vacant, so of course you had drugs, you had prostitutes, you had wild dogs. Anthony loves his community. He's worked for years at a public park in the area, in full view of the bridge. And he saw the systematic
然后任由它们闲置在那里。它们是空置的，所以理所当然地，你会有毒品、妓女和流浪狗。安东尼热爱他的社区。他在该地区的一个公共公园工作多年，可以清楚地看到大桥。他看到了他的社区系统性地
destruction of his neighborhood up close. The people next door to that house, they sat there looking at a vacant house for years until they are begging Manny Maroon to buy their house. Sometimes the sales agents gave no indication they were there on behalf of the Maroons. They'd represent companies with names like Mexican Town Real Estate Company. Some unsuspecting homeowners were desperate to get out of the area that was being hollowed out and collapsing from blight. They were happy to so. Only later did they learn the truth about who bought their property. Maroon wanted to buy up the land near the bridge so he could one day expand its entry plaza and collect more tolls.
遭到破坏的近景。那栋房子隔壁的人们坐在那里看着一栋空置的房子多年，直到他们乞求曼尼·马龙买下他们的房子。有时销售代理没有表现出他们是代表马龙家族来的迹象。他们代表名字像墨西哥城房地产公司这样的公司。一些毫无戒心的房主急于离开这个正在被掏空、因荒废而崩溃的区域。他们很乐意这样做。直到后来他们才得知是谁买下了他们的房产的真相。马龙想买下桥附近的土地，以便有朝一日扩建其入口广场并收取更多过桥费。
But he bought lots of other property, too. Enough to become a true baron of Detroit real estate. One website that tracks landlords in the city estimates the Maroons have owned as many as 978 properties in Detroit alone. And the Windsor Star estimates that at one point Maroon owned another. 139 properties in Windsor at the bridge's entry point on the Canadian side. A lot of the property the Maroons were buying wasn't anywhere near the bridge. And once they owned them, the Maroons weren't that interested in doing anything with them. In fact, the Maroons accumulated so many blight tickets over the years that they struck
但他还买了许多其他房产。足以成为底特律房地产真正的男爵。一个追踪该市房东的网站估计，仅在底特律，马龙家族就曾拥有多达978处房产。温莎星报估计，马龙在加拿大一侧桥梁入口处的温莎还曾拥有另外139处房产。马龙家族购买的许多房产根本不在桥附近。一旦拥有了它们，马龙家族对用它们做任何事情都不太感兴趣。事实上，多年来马龙家族积累了如此多的荒废罚单，以至于他们与市政府达成了不止一项协议，以商定的总额支付罚款。
more than one deal with the city to pay them off in negotiated lump sums. This kind of thing, buying property and just letting it go to seed, it was happening a lot in Detroit around this time. The city was declining rapidly in the 80s, and land was selling for cheap. That meant land speculators could sweep in, take advantage of an economic downturn, and hoard real estate just in case Detroit ever made a comeback without having to worry about keeping it up. Who was going to foreclose on you? The city? They were broke. If you can buy that property for $500, $1,000, $3,000, I guess you're investing that on a speculation that hopefully one day, someday, somebody comes and wants to buy that property,
这种事情，买下房产却任其荒废，在这个时期的底特律经常发生。80年代这座城市迅速衰落，土地售价低廉。这意味着土地投机者可以乘虚而入，利用经济低迷的机会囤积房地产，以防底特律有朝一日东山再起，而不必担心维持其维护。谁会对你取消抵押品赎回权？市政府？他们破产了。如果你能以500美元、1,000美元、3,000美元的价格买下这处房产，我想你是在进行投机投资，希望有朝一日，某天，有人来想买下这处房产，并且他们愿意支付你几千美元购买价格的好几倍，你知道，这让这些房产变得有价值。最坏的情况是你因拖欠税款而失去房产。但这是一场长达30年的赌博，到头来你损失的只是最初的成本。马迪·马龙的收购狂潮规模如此之大，以至于他最终涉足了底特律历史上的一个重要篇章。1992年，马龙买下了密歇根中央车站，这是科克敦西南部社区的一个巨大的前火车站。这个车站是底特律早期时代的一个遗迹，当时人们仍然乘火车通勤。其巨大、铺有瓷砖的天花板还迎来了大迁徙期间新到来的移民和黑人美国人。这座建筑被称为底特律的埃利斯岛。
and they're willing to pay you multiples of that, you know, a few thousand dollar purchase price, and the properties become valuable. And the worst case scenario is you lose the property to tax foreclosure. But that is a 30-year gamble, and then you're only out your original cost. Maddie Maroon's buying spree got so big that he eventually landed on a major piece of Detroit history. In 1992, Maroon purchased Michigan Central, a massive former train station in the southwest neighborhood of Corktown. The station was a relic of an earlier era in Detroit, when people still commuted by train. And its giant, tiled ceilings also welcomed newly arriving migrants and black Americans coming up during the Great Migration. The building was known as Detroit's Ellis Island.
密歇根中央车站即使在马迪·马龙买下它时也已经大不如前了，但他对它什么也没做，除了在房产周围建造围栏，并在旧窗户被劫掠者砸碎后安装了一些新窗户。一个雄伟的交通枢纽在众目睽睽之下腐烂。对很多人来说，这感觉像是底特律现状的一个隐喻。卡尔·克雷格，底特律电子乐先驱，将这座建筑引为自己和其他音乐家在汽车城开发这种革命性新后工业声音的奇怪灵感来源。这是底特律的一个典型例子。结构太美了。
Michigan Central had seen better days even when Maddie Maroon bought it, but he did nothing with it, besides building a fence around the property and putting in some windows after the old ones had been busted by looters. A majestic transportation hub rotting away in plain sight. To a lot of people, it felt like a metaphor for what had become of Detroit. Carl Craig, a Detroit techno pioneer, cited the building as a weird kind of inspiration for himself and other musicians as they developed this revolution. new post-industrial sound in the Motor City. This is a typical example of Detroit. Just beautiful structure.
当我还是个孩子的时候，它正在蓬勃发展。而现在20年过去了，它完全被毁了。到了20世纪90年代，密歇根中央车站成了涂鸦和拾荒者的磁铁。它体现了人们闻之色变的底特律“废墟色情”刻板印象。城市探险家在里面探险，惊叹于铁锈带的蹂躏。就像2012年纪录片《底特律乌托邦》中的这个片段，一位歌剧男高音在密歇根中央车站漫步。墙壁正在崩塌，布满涂鸦。
It was booming when I was a kid. And now 20 years later, it's just totally fucked up. By the 1990s, Michigan Central was a magnet for graffiti and scavengers. It embodied the dreaded Detroit stereotype of ruin porn. Urban explorers went spulunking inside to gawk at the ravages of the rust belt. Like in this clip from the 2012 documentary, Detropia, in which an opera tenor wanders through Michigan Central. The walls are crumbling and filled with graffiti.
这看起来像是僵尸电影里的东西。这就是我认为整个情况最悲哀的地方。大桥的最初所有者试图在底特律的繁荣时期帮助其发展经济。几十年后，新的所有者走上另一条路，并加速了该市灾难性的衰落。尽管他们的许多房产失修，但马龙家族仍然赚取了巨大利润，因为他们的主要业务——大使桥，在1992年北美自由贸易协定通过后变得更加不可或缺，
It looks like something out of a zombie movie. And this is what I think is so sad about the whole situation. The original owners of the bridge were trying to help grow Detroit's economy during its boom years. Decades later, the new owners were coming out on the other end and helping to accelerate the city's disastrous fall. While many of their properties fell into disrepair, the Maroons still made huge profits because their main business, the Ambassador Bridge, became even more indispensable after the passage of NAFTA,
还记得北美自由贸易协定吗？你知道的，那个旨在消除美国和加拿大之间关税的协议。无论如何，北美自由贸易协定导致两国之间的商业活动大幅增加，并使这座桥变得至关重要。《福布斯》杂志曾估计这座桥每年带来6000万美元的收入。在北美自由贸易协定通过后，马迪·马龙在与底特律的交易中变得明显更有野心。他采取了一个相当厚颜无耻的举动来扩大他的业务，在第一座桥旁边开始建造第二座桥。大使桥上的交通流量增加得如此之多，以至于显然对另一座桥有需求。马龙家族知道这一点。
in 1992. Remember NAFTA? You know, the agreement designed to eliminate tariffs between the United States and Canada. Anyhow, NAFTA led to a big increase in commerce between the two countries and made the bridge essential. Forbes magazine once estimated the bridge makes $60 million in revenue every year. After the passage of NAFTA, Maddie Maroon became notably more ambitious in his dealings with Detroit. He made a pretty brazen move to expand his business. by starting construction on a second bridge, right beside the first one. Traffic had increased so much on the ambassador, there was clearly demand for another bridge. The Maroons knew that.
他们也知道，如果他们不顺应这种需求，第二座桥将由别人建造，一个会威胁到他们垄断地位的人。马迪·马龙没有获得底特律市、温莎市或任何人的许可就开始建造新桥。事实上，马迪·马龙本应该做一些完全不同的事情，一些对社区有益的事情。2004年，马龙与该市签署了一项价值2.58亿美元的协议，用于一项名为“门户项目”的倡议。密歇根州交通部、居民、利益相关者和社区领导人正在联手改善通往密歇根州、该地区和底特律的国际门户。对于门户项目，政府将修建更多的道路来缓解交通压力，作为交换，马龙承诺修建入口，将桥梁连接到高速公路系统，这样卡车就不必再穿过墨西哥城社区了。
They also knew that if they didn't act on that demand, the second bridge would be built by someone else, someone who would threaten their monopoly. Maddie Maroon didn't have permission from the city of Detroit or the city of Windsor or from anybody to start building a new bridge. In fact, Maddie Maroon was supposed to be doing something completely different, something positive for the community. In 2004, Maroon signed a $258 million deal with the city for an initiative called The Gateway Project. The Michigan Department of Transportation, residents, stakeholders, and community leaders are teaming up to improve the international gateway into Michigan, the region, and Detroit. For the Gateway Project, the government would build more roads to ease traffic, and in exchange, Maroon promised to build entryways to connect the bridge to the highway system, so trucks would no longer have to drive through the Mexican Town neighborhood.
这似乎对每个人来说都是一笔划算的交易。但马迪·马龙的公司没有信守承诺，而是在2007年开始建造第二座桥。他们没有走多远。最后，他们只建造了两个不与任何东西相连的坡道。我们现在称它为“正义的 Dukes 桥”。所以就像，你知道的，它甚至从未建成。它就像一个向上的坡道。多年来，马迪·马龙承诺采取行动并连接高速公路。
It seemed like a great deal for everybody. But instead of holding up his end of the bargain, Maddie Maroon's company started construction on a second bridge in 2007. They didn't get very far. In the end, they only built two ramps that didn't connect to anything. We call it the Dukes a Hazard Bridge right now. So it's like, you know, it's never even built. It's just like a ramp going up. For years, Maddie Maroon promised to take action and connect up with the highway.
但他从来没有这样做。他所做的只是建造了那座通往哪里的桥，声称它是门户协议的一部分。这座城市显得无能为力。他们等了五年，等马龙履行他那部分的承诺。社区成员以戏剧性的公开抗议来反击这种行为。安东尼·贝内维德斯记得其中一次。有人躺在路上，所以他的卡车过不去。字面意义上躺在路上，他们就是这么投入。
But he never did. All he did was build that bridge to nowhere, claiming it was part of the gateway deal. The city appeared helpless. They waited five years for Maroon to hold up his part of the bargain. Members of the community fought back against this kind of behavior with dramatic public protests. Anthony Benavides remembers one of them. There's people that laid on the road so his trucks couldn't go through. Literally laid on the road, that's how involved they were.
他们真的把身体挡在卡车前面。100多人组成了一根人链，封锁了通往大桥的通道。一些民选官员加入了他们的行列。占领运动也是如此。抗议活动超出了99%。抗议活动蔓延开来。另类周报《都市时报》发表了一幅漫画，将马龙描绘成《辛普森一家》中的伯恩斯先生。抗议者抬着一个巨大的马迪·马龙木偶，在密歇根中央车站前游行，
They literally put their bodies in front of trucks. More than 100 people formed a human chain to block access to the bridge. Some elected officials joined them. So did the Occupy movement. And the protests spread out of 99%. And the protests spread out. The Metro Times, the Alt Weekly, published a cartoon depicting Maroon as Mr. Burns from The Simpsons. Protesters carried a giant puppet of Maddie Maroon and paraded him in front of Michigan Central,
在那里，他们指责他拥有如此多的荒废房产。我来这里是因为我们受够了马迪·马龙和他破损的、拆毁的、破旧的房屋，还把它们租给人们。这太疯狂了，他拥有那么多钱。他是个亿万富翁。他是首席执行官。他是唯一一个致富的人。尽管有这些抗议以及来自史蒂夫·托巴赫曼和拉希达·特莱布等政客的推诿，马龙家族基本上仍然随心所欲，
where they chastised him for owning so many blighted properties. I'm here because we are sick and tired of Maddie Maroon. and his broken, torn down, his houses that's dilapidated, renting them to people. This is crazy with all the money that he has. He's a billionaire. He's a CEO. He's the only one getting rich. Despite these protests and pushback from politicians like Steve Tobachman and Rashida Talib, the Maroons still largely got their way,
部分原因是马迪·马龙在密歇根州花了大笔游说资金。多年来，每当该州提出解决该桥问题的前景时，这些努力很快就会夭折。他们也以诉讼成性而闻名。为了避免旷日持久的法律战，地方政府通常认为最好的前进道路是就所有桥梁事宜与该家族达成交易。但面对对马龙家族的如此多反对意见，
partly because Maddie Maroons spent heavily on lobbying in Michigan. For years when the state would raise the prospect of dealing with the bridge's problems, those efforts would die quickly. They are also known to be very litigious. To avoid drawn-out legal battles, local governments usually decided the best way forward was to cut deals with the family on all bridge matters. But with so much pushback against the Maroons,
一场摊牌变得不可避免。2012年1月，马龙和他的长期得力助手丹·斯坦珀被传唤到县法官面前。对他们在门户项目上的拖延感到厌烦，法官下令他们两人在监狱里过夜。马龙当时84岁。这个城市中最富有、最有权势的人之一
a showdown became inevitable. In January 2012, Maroon and his longtime right-hand man, Dan Stamper, were hauled before a county judge. Fed up with their foot-dragging on the Gateway Project, the judge ordered both of them to spend one night in jail. Maroon was 84 years old. One of the richest and most powerful men in the city
被扔进了县拘留所。约翰·加拉格尔对这一点记忆犹新。令人惊讶的是，像他这样地位的人，我的意思是，一个亿万富翁商人，会因为抗拒法院命令而被投入监狱。监禁对马迪·马龙来说并不是太糟糕。他获得了批准，让底特律运动俱乐部（该市一家豪华的会员制场所）
was thrown in county lockup. John Gallagher remembers this well. It was astonishing that a guy of his stature, I mean, a billionaire businessman, would be thrown in jail for resisting, you know, a court order. The stay-in-the-pen wasn't too bad for Maddie Maroon. He got approval to have the Detroit Athletic Club, a swanky member-only venue in the city.
那天派人送来了一顿订制晚餐。当他出来时，他的脸上带着灿烂的笑容。嗨。你好吗？我很好。出来感觉怎么样？我热爱我们的国家。世界上最好的国家。
send over a catered dinner that night. When he got out, he had a big smile on his face. Hi. How are you? I'm fine. How do you feel to be out? I love our country. Best country in the world.
很长一段时间里，马龙家族的大桥垄断似乎永远不会结束。最终，唯一有影响力和能力与马龙家族抗衡的群体是“伟大纯净的北方”。是的。前来营救美国。当加拿大开始出拳时，关于大使桥未来的最终战役开始了。加拿大最高部长们实际上在某件事上与马龙家族达成了一致。应该有一座连接底特律和温莎的第二座桥。他们只是不想让马迪拥有它。从2004年开始，加拿大政府提出了一系列建造第二座桥的提案。他们的桥将直接与高速公路相连，使卡车司机的行程
For a long time, it seemed like the Maroons Bridge Monopoly would never end. Ultimately, the only group of people with the clout and the ability to stand up to the Maroons was the Great White North. Yes. came to the rescue to bail out America. And when Canada came swinging, the final battle over the future of the ambassador began. Canada's top ministers actually agreed with the maroons about something. There should be a second bridge connecting Detroit to Windsor. They just didn't want Maddie to own it. Beginning in 2004, the Canadian government made a series of proposals to build a second bridge. Their bridge would link up directly with the freeway, making the trip
更轻松，并改善底特律社区的生活质量。它将引入竞争，并将带回人行道。大使桥多年前就已经关闭了他们的人行道。一位名叫罗伊·诺顿的加拿大外交官是这项努力的公开面孔。他明确表示，打破马龙家族的大桥垄断绝非易事。我承认自己曾定期产生这样的幻觉：一辆马龙家族拥有的18轮大卡车朝我压过来，在我穿梭于密歇根州时将我逼下公路。密歇根州的底线是，马龙家族获胜。
easier for truckers and the quality of life better for the neighborhoods in Detroit. It would introduce competition, and it would bring back pedestrian walkways. The ambassador had closed theirs years ago. A Canadian diplomat named Roy Norton was the public face of the effort. He made it clear, breaking up the Maroon's bridge monopoly would be no easy task. I confess to having had periodic visions of a Maroon-owned 18-wheeler bearing down on me and forcing me off the road as I crisscrossed the state of Michigan. The bottom line in Michigan, the Maroons win.
至少从历史上看，情况一直如此。诺顿称马龙家族为骗子和恶棍。他斥责那些接受他们竞选资金的立法者，并建议应该调查整个家族是否违反了反垄断法。这种强硬的言论得到了回报。2012年，双方达成协议。将建造一座新桥并由其控制。完全由加拿大政府控制。
At least historically, that's been the case. Norton called the Maroons liars and scoundrels. He chastised the lawmakers who took their campaign money and suggested the whole family should be investigated for violating antitrust laws. This tough talk paid off. In 2012, an agreement was reached. A second bridge would be built and controlled. controlled entirely by the Canadian government.
它将被命名为戈迪·豪桥，以纪念这位加拿大冰球明星，他职业生涯的大部分时间都在底特律红翼队度过，这是双边团结的象征。还有一个好处。加拿大将承担新桥的全部费用。美国纳税人不用出一分钱。这让马龙家族很不高兴。另一座桥意味着他们必须采取有竞争力的定价并进行昂贵的改进才能维持生存。
It would be named the Gordy Howe Bridge, in honor of the Canadian hockey star who played most of his career with the Detroit Red Wings, a symbol of bi-national unity. And here's the sweetener. Canada would pay the entire cost of the new bridge. American taxpayers would pay nothing. This didn't sit well with the Maroons. Another bridge would mean they'd have to adopt competitive pricing and make costly improvements just to stay afloat.
所以他们想方设法阻止戈迪·豪桥的建设。马迪·马龙的儿子马修向媒体阐述了他们的观点。我们在密歇根州有一家经营了83年的企业，为城市和州做出了经济贡献。马龙家族采取了一些相当激进的战术进行反击。2011年，当戈迪·豪桥仍处于规划阶段时，在拟议桥址附近的社区张贴了一堆黄色的驱逐通知。很多人理所当然地吓坏了。
So they pulled out all the stops to try and prevent the Gordy Howe from being built. Maddie Maroon's son, Matthew, made his case to the media. We've got a Michigan business that's been here for 83 years and contributed economically to the city and the state. The Maroons fought back with some pretty aggressive tactics. In 2011, when the Gordy Howe was still in the planning stage, a bunch of yellow eviction notices went up in a neighborhood close to the proposed bridge site. A lot of people, understandably, freaked out.
但这些通知是假的，是一种旨在鼓动对戈迪·豪桥反对情绪的恐慌战术。一个保守的游说团体“美国繁荣”承认制造了虚假的驱逐通知。然后是投票箱。马迪·马龙花费了3000多万美元让密歇根州选民通过了一项名为“第6号提案”的修正案。第6号提案将使所有未来的桥梁项目都要经过州和地方选民的全民公决。整个事情旨在使像戈迪·豪桥这样的项目的批准
But the notices were fake, a scare tactic meant to drum up opposition to the Gordy Howe Bridge. A conservative lobbying group, Americans for Prosperity, took credit for the fake eviction notices. Then there was the ballot box. Maddie Maroon spent more than $30 million to get an amendment passed by Michigan voters called Proposal 6. Proposal 6 would make all future bridge projects subject to a referendum by both states. and local voters. The whole thing was designed to make approval for projects like the Gordy Howe Bridge
变得更加困难。由马迪·马龙支持的团体播放了广告，暗示选民不知何故必须为戈迪·豪桥付费。并且第6号提案将阻止这种情况发生。以下是密歇根州选民投票赞成的原因。
much more difficult. Groups supported by Maddie Maroon ran ads implying that voters somehow would have to pay for the Gordy Howe Bridge. And that Proposal 6 would stop that from happening. Here's why Michigan voters are voting yes.
关于第6号提案，没有所谓的免费桥。没有所谓的免费桥。总得有人付钱。我不在乎谁拥有这座桥。我只在乎在甚至没有被征求意见的情况下为新桥买单。赞成意味着我们拥有权力。反对意味着我们把权力拱手让给政客。
On Proposal 6, there's no such thing as a free bridge. There's no such thing as a free bridge. Someone pays. I don't care who owns the bridge. All I care about is paying for a new one without even being asked. Yes means we have the power. No means we give it away to the politicians.
他们将他们的竞选活动命名为“人民应该决定”。最终，大桥修正案失败了，60%的选民拒绝了它。尽管如此，马龙家族并没有轻易罢休。马龙家族将新的桥梁管理局告上法庭，提起了一场又一场诉讼以推迟其建设，并一直上诉到州最高法院。最终，他们的法律途径用尽了，但他们成功地将事情拖延了六年。2018年，在特朗普总统的第一任期内，加拿大这座桥终于要开始建设了。所以马迪·马龙孤注一掷地试图拯救他家族的垄断地位。
They called their campaign, the people should decide. Ultimately, the bridge amendment failed, with 60% of voters rejecting it. Still, the Maroon family wouldn't go down without a fight. The Maroons took the new bridge authority to court, filing lawsuit after lawsuit to delay its construction, and appealing all the way to the state Supreme Court. Eventually, they ran out of legal avenues, but they were able to drag things out for six years. In 2018, during President Trump's first term in office, the Canadian bridge was due to finally begin construction. So Maddie Maroon tried a Hail Mary to save his family's monopoly.
亲爱的总统先生，在底特律的美加之间，有人提议建造两座宏伟的新桥。一座是美国制造、美国所有。它使用美国制造的钢材，有5000名美国工人。另一座将是加拿大制造、加拿大所有、加拿大工人。谁知道谁会制造钢材呢？这则广告在福克斯新闻上播放，希望特朗普能看到并进行干预。鉴于这位总统以经常看福克斯新闻而闻名，这个计划并非不可行。在这则广告中，马龙家族试图将他们对桥梁项目的想法描绘成爱国的替代方案。
Dear Mr. President, there are two grand new bridges being proposed in Detroit between America and Canada. One is American-made, American-owned. It uses American-made steel, 5,000 American workers. The other would be Canadian-made, Canadian-owned, Canadian workers. Who knows who would make the steel? This ad ran on Fox News in the hopes that Trump would see it and intervene. Given that the president was known to watch Fox News constantly, it wasn't a bad plan. In this ad, the Maroons tried to paint their idea for a bridge project as a patriotic alternative.
选择美国。谢谢你，先生。美国署名。尽管如此，我们称之为游说吧。特朗普从未进行干预。戈迪·豪桥终于在当年6月破土动工。今年秋天，戈迪·豪桥将正式开通。这是美加友谊的全新象征。
Choose American. Thank you, sir. Signed America. Despite all of this, let's just call it lobbying. Trump never intervened. And the Gordyhow Bridge finally broke ground that June. This fall, the Gordyhow Bridge is set to open. It's a brand new symbol of Canadian-American friendship.
在这个两国及其领导人关系处于自1812年战争（当时英国军队烧毁了白宫）以来最低点的时刻。正如另一个加拿大人曾经说过的，这难道不是很讽刺吗？自从失去桥梁垄断权以来，马龙家族已经退居幕后。就在戈迪·豪桥于2018年开工建设的同一个月，该家族以9000万美元将密歇根中央车站卖给了福特汽车公司。2020年，马迪·马龙因心力衰竭去世，享年93岁。
At a moment when relations between the two countries and their leaders are at their lowest point since the war of 1812, when British troops burned down the White House. As another Canadian once said, isn't it ironic? Since the loss of the bridge monopoly, the Maroons have taken a step back. The same month that Gordyhow Bridge began construction in 2018, the family sold Michigan Central to the Ford Motor Company for $90 million. In 2020, Maddie Maroon died at the age of 93 from heart failure.
他已经将家族企业（包括这座桥）的控制权移交给了他的儿子马修。自那以后，马龙家族在城市的新领域继续他们的清盘扩张，与其他的商业投资挂钩。但基调和家族的战术已经缓和。他们举办了公开活动。他们与底特律西南部达成了一项社区协议
He had already transferred control of the family's enterprises, including the bridge, to his son Matthew. Since then, the Maroons have continued their blockbusting in new areas of the city, connected to other business ventures. But the tone and the family's tactics have softened. They've held public events. They reached a community agreement with Southwest Detroit
明确界定了他们可以在哪里建造以及哪里不能建造。今年夏天早些时候，他们拆除了通往哪里的桥。至于密歇根中央车站，天哪，福特汽车公司花费了近10亿美元对其进行翻新，将其变成了一个科技中心和旅游胜地，并配有一家豪华酒店。他们将整个项目变成了一项重大的社区工作。他们甚至欢迎车站的劫掠者归还他们偷走的具有历史意义的东西，不问出处。许多人确实这样做了。
that clearly defines where they can build and where they can't. And earlier this summer, they tore down the bridge to nowhere. And Michigan Central, oh boy, Ford Motor Company spent nearly a billion dollars renovating it and turned it into a tech hub and tourist destination with a luxury hotel on the way. They turned the whole project into a major community effort. And they even welcomed the station's looters to return the historic stuff they stole, no questions asked. And many did.
当这座建筑去年重新开放时，它包括了一个关于所有归还物品的公开展览。重新开业的音乐会吸引到底特律最优秀的音乐家，如阿姆、黛安娜·罗斯和杰克·怀特。在新桥开通和密歇根中央车站重新开放之间，底特律人现在有很多理由为这座城市庆祝。2013年，底特律申请了美国历史上最大规模的城市破产。但从这次令人尴尬的失败中，情况开始好转。新的人口和企业迁入，开发商以闪电般的速度重塑了这座城市。
When the building reopened last year, it included a public exhibit of all that report. patriated loop. A reopening concert brought out Detroit's finest musicians, like Eminem, Diana Ross, and Jack White. Between the new bridge and Michigan Central reopening, there are a lot of reasons for Detroiters to celebrate the city right now. In 2013, Detroit filed the largest municipal bankruptcy in American history. But from this embarrassing failure, things started looking up. New people and businesses have moved in, and developers reshaped the city at lightning speed.
新桥一直是这种兴奋的一部分。这里是约翰·加拉格尔。这是一个代际变化，一些年轻人进来了，一些对这座城市没有像他们的父母那样带有负面形象的人进来了。这座城市开始好转。而且，你知道，到2015年、2020年，很明显许多伟大的事情正在发生。很难不注意到底特律周围态度的转变。当我在密歇根的一个欢迎中心采访凯茜·温德勒时，她兴奋地指着窗外的人行道，不是指着大使桥，而是指着其他东西。
The new bridge has been part of that excitement. Here's John Gallagher. There's a generational change where some younger people came in, some people who didn't have the same negative image of the city that maybe their parents had or something. And the city just began to turn around. And, you know, by 2015, 2020, it was pretty apparent that a lot of great stuff was happening. It's hard not to see the shift in attitudes around Detroit. When I interviewed Kathy Wendler at a Michigan welcome center, she excitedly pointed through the window to the sidewalk outside, not to the Ambassador Bridge, but to something else.
我不知道他们是否拍到了那对带着两个孩子走过的人行道上的夫妇。但在某个时候，这个社区绝不会成为一个家庭搬进来的地方。对凯茜·温德勒来说，这是她过去几十年一直在为之奋斗的标志，
I don't know if they just caught that couple with the two kids walking by. but at one point to this neighborhood would have never been a place where a family moved in. For Kathy Wendler, this was a sign of what she's been fighting for over the past few decades,
汽车城的复兴。这是巨大的，特别是对于那些坚持下来并说我们在底特律养育了我们的孩子，我们把他们送到这里的学校，仍然存在的房产正在得到投资，新建设正在进行。有希望。总是有希望的。如果你能活得足够久，总会有希望的。
the revitalization of the Motor City. It's tremendous, especially for the people who held out and said we raised our kids here, we sent them to school here, properties that are still here are getting invested in, new constructions going on. There is hope. There's always hope. If you can live long enough, there's always hope.
几十年来，马龙家族一直被底特律的许多人视为城市恶棍。如果是由另一个家族拥有这座桥，事情可能会有不同的结果。但凯茜·温德勒说，这并不重要。对她来说，这里有一个更简单的教训。国际边境口岸不应该是私有的。大使桥最近因为一些相当令人不安的原因登上了新闻。广告之后会有更多关于安德鲁·莱平的报道。所以我和制作人安德鲁·莱平在这里。嗨，安德鲁。嗨，罗曼。所以你住在密歇根。你实际上多久？使用一次大使桥。
For decades, the Maroons have been seen as civic villains by lots of people in Detroit. Maybe things would have turned out differently if another family had owned the bridge. But Kathy Wendler says, it doesn't matter. To her, there's a much simpler lesson. here. International border crossing shouldn't be privately owned. The Ambassador Bridge has been in the news recently for some pretty upsetting reasons. More with Andrew Lapin after this. So I'm here with producer Andrew Lapin. Hey, Andrew. Hey, Roman. So you live in Michigan. And how often do you actually? use the ambassador bridge.
好吧。嗯，我不是长途卡车司机，所以我不是一直在使用它。但每当我进入加拿大时，是的，我确实为马龙企业付出了我应得的份额。几周前，我和家人去多伦多旅行。我们开车过桥。我们付了过桥费。然后我们穿过了通常的八到十个红绿灯，这些红绿灯将大桥与温莎一侧的泛加拿大高速公路隔开。所以我们有了完整的卡车司机体验。那么你对即将开通的新戈迪·豪桥有多兴奋？我认为这真的很酷。
All right. Well, I'm not a long-haul trucker, so I'm not using it all the time. But whenever I go into Canada, yeah, I do pay my fair share of coin to Maroon Enterprises. A few weeks ago, the family and I took a trip to Toronto. We drove over the bridge. We paid our toll. And then we sat through the customary eight to ten traffic lights that separate the bridge from the trans-Canadian highway on the Windsor side. So we got the full trucker experience. And so how excited are you for the new Gordy Hombridge to open? I think this is really cool.
奸的。奸吧我不是长途货车司机所以我不是一直在使用它。但是每次我去加拿大我确实会向马鲁恩企业支付我该付的过路费。几周前我和家人一起去多伦多旅行。我们开车过桥。我们付了过路费。然后我们在温莎央一侧就是把桥和加拿大跨境高速全部隔开的那几个惯例的八到十个交通信号灯前停了下。所以我们体验了完整的货车司生活。那你对新的戈地霍姆布分套页开放有多满怀期待呢。我认为这真的很标志性。
Everybody here is talking about it. I should add that like Gordy Howe was also the originator of the phrase elbows up, which has become this like Canadian anti-Trump rallying cry, which I just think is kind of funny in the current moment. We did recently hear that even though it was slated to open up this fall, it might actually get delayed until next year. That's looking like more and more of a distinct possibility. And that's because the Canadian government, which is paying for all the construction, has not yet fully built out the entry ramps.
这里每个人都在谈论这件事。我应该补充一下，戈迪·豪（Gordy Howe）也是“抬起手肘”（elbows up）这个短语的始作俑者，这个短语已经成为了加拿大反特朗普的战斗口号，在当前的情境下我觉得这挺有意思的。我们最近确实听说，尽管这座大桥原本计划在今年秋天开通，但实际上可能会推迟到明年。这种可能性看起来越来越大。这是因为正在为所有建设买单的加拿大政府，目前还没有完全建好入口匝道。
So even though the bridge itself is they say 98% complete, something like that, some of the surrounding infrastructure isn't quite there yet. Well, there really is nothing easy about the infrastructure, you know, bridging these two countries at this point, is there? No, I guess that's why they only do it once every hundred years. So one of the reasons we want to do this story about the Ambassador Bridge is that it's, been in the news recently. So could you fill us in on some of the recent developments? Yeah, for sure. It's been in the news for a pretty dark reason. So the ambassador is obviously an international crossing, and there's been a lot of focus in this new Trump administration on the border and on various international crossings, mostly on the southern border, but also here in the
所以，尽管大桥本身据说已经完成了98%左右，但周围的一些基础设施还没有完全建好。好吧，在这个阶段，在连接这两个国家的基础设施方面，真的没有什么容易的事，对吧？不，我想这就是为什么他们每百年才这么做一次的原因。所以我们想报道大使桥这个故事的原因之一是它最近上了新闻。那么你能给我们介绍一下最近的一些进展吗？是的，当然。它上新闻是因为一个相当黑暗的原因。所以大使桥显然是一个国际通道，在这个新的特朗普政府中，人们对边境和各种国际通道给予了极大的关注，主要是在南部边境，但也包括这里的
north. We just had Christy Nome, Trump's Homeland Security Secretary in town recently doing an event called Secure Our Northern Border, where she claimed that gang members from South and Central America might be plotting to cross the ambassador. And I don't really know how likely that is. But concurrent with that, we have seen increased detainments of migrants at the bridge, mostly by Customs and Border Patrol, but also increasingly by ICE. So there has been more activity at the Canadian border. I mean, we mostly hear about news on the southern border, but the Canadian border is also showing a lot of activity. Yeah. And at the ambassador, there's like this unusual twist to it that is so strange, which is that this bridge, it's not particularly well marked. Like only in the last
北部。特朗普的国土安全部长克里斯蒂·诺姆（Kristi Noem）最近刚刚来到镇上，举办了一场名为“确保我们北部边境安全”的活动，她在活动中声称，来自南美和中美洲的帮派成员可能正在密谋穿过大使桥。我真的不知道这种可能性有多大。但与此同时，我们看到在桥上被拘留的移民人数有所增加，主要由海关和边境保护局（CBP）负责，但移民和海关执法局（ICE）也越来越多地参与其中。因此，加拿大边境的活动确实增多了。我的意思是，我们听到的大多是关于南部边境的新闻，但加拿大边境也显示出很多活动。是的。而且在大桥上，有一个非常奇怪的离奇转折，就是这座大桥标志并不是特别明显。就像直到最近
several years has it actually connected directly with the highway. And the signs that tell you you're going on to the bridge come at you really fast. And it's sort of notorious because it says bridge to Canada, no reentry to the U.S. And so if you take that, you are stuck. You kind of have to go over the bridge. There was a Detroit free press investigation recently that found, oh, actually there is a way that is completely unmarked where if you make this turn, you don't have to go on the bridge and pay the toll, but most people just don't know about it. So they're pushed into the bridge, into this toll lane. They're forced into Canada. They have to turn back around, which means they have to get processed by border security. And we've just seen a lot of migrants get nabbed this way since the
几年它才真正直接与高速公路相连。那些告诉你正在上桥的标志出现得非常快。它有点声名狼藉，因为上面写着“通往加拿大之桥，禁止重返美国”。所以如果你走了那条路，你就被困住了。你基本上必须过桥。最近《底特律自由报》的一项调查发现，哦，实际上有一条完全没有标记的路，如果你在那里转弯，你不必过桥也不必交过路费，但大多数人只是不知道这一点。所以他们被逼上了桥，进入了这条收费车道。他们被迫去往加拿大。他们必须掉头回来，这意味着他们必须经过边境安全部门的处理。我们看到自从今年年初以来
start of the year. Like a lot of people make this turn by accident, but just a lot of people make this turn by accident, but just in the first part of this year from January to March, the statistic came out that more than 210 people were detained at this bridge crossing, and more than 90% of them had crossed onto the bridge by accident. 90%. Oh, my God. Yeah, this is a number that comes from the American Civil Liberties Union of Michigan and the offices of Rashida Talib, who's the Detroit Congresswoman, who made this congressional visit in April
有大量移民以这种方式被捕。就像很多人不小心转了这个弯，但就在今年年初的这段时间，从1月到3月，有统计数据显示，在这座桥的过境点有210多人被拘留，其中90%以上都是不小心上了桥。90%？哦，天哪。是的，这个数字来自密歇根州美国公民自由联盟（ACLU）以及底特律女国会议员拉希达·特莱布（Rashida Tlaib）的办公室，她在4月份对
to this detention site. right next to the bridge that's run by CBP. So I spoke recently with someone at the Michigan Immigrant Rights Center, their legal group that helps immigrants in the state. So they worked with the ACLU to like get these numbers, which they say come directly from CBP, including that stat about more than 90% crossing it by accident. We don't really know how many people have been detained in this manner since March.
这个由CBP运营的紧邻大桥的拘留点进行了国会访问。所以我最近和密歇根州移民权利中心的一个人谈过，这是该州帮助移民的法律组织。所以他们与美国公民自由联盟合作获取了这些数字，他们称这些数字直接来自CBP，包括关于90%以上的人是不小心过桥的统计数据。我们真的不知道自3月份以来有多少人以这种方式被拘留。
So since then, I've been told that, you know, CBP has kind of stopped holding migrants in these windowless detention. facilities, but that's only because they've farmed out the responsibility of holding the migrants to ICE, which is using this privatized facility at the other end of the state. Oh, my God. So have any news stories leaked out about who is getting detained and, you know, what the tragedy of their detainment is all about? Yeah, there are some pretty horrifying stories here, just to give you a sense of just how
所以从那以后，我听说，你知道，CBP有点停止将移民关押在这些没有窗户的拘留设施中，但这只是因为他们把关押移民的责任外包给了ICE，而ICE正在使用该州另一端的这个私有化设施。哦，天哪。那么，有没有关于谁被拘留以及他们的拘留悲剧究竟是怎么回事的新闻报道流传出来呢？是的，这里有一些非常可怕的故事，只是为了让你了解这一切发生得有多么
incidental all this tends to happen. There was this one mother with her family, and they were just trying to get to Costco, but they had accidentally mapped out directions to the Costco in Windsor, which took them across the bridge, which resulted in the CBP throwing them in a detention facility for several days. And then there was this other very well-publicized story from the New York Times, this Venezuelan man named Ricardo Prada Vasquez, who had been working in Detroit as a delivery driver. And so in January, actually, like a few days before Trump's swearing in, Vasquez made a wrong
偶然。曾有这样一位母亲和她的家人，他们只是想去好市多（Costco），但他们不小心用地图规划了去温莎好市多路线，这把他们带过了桥，导致CBP把他们扔进拘留所好几天。然后还有另一个来自《纽约时报》的广为人知的报道，这是一个名叫里卡多·普拉达·巴斯克斯（Ricardo Prada Vasquez）的委内瑞拉男子，他一直在底特律做送货司机。所以在1月，实际上就在特朗普宣誓就职前几天，巴斯克斯错误地
turn onto the Ambassador Bridge and was added to a deportation list. And then, you know, months later, his family had not heard from him. And he essentially seems to have vanished from the government's records of migrants that they had deported. So there was this period of time where he seemed to have been functionally disappeared by the U.S. government. People just didn't know where he was. Since then, there have been reports that indicate that he was sent to Seekot, which is a notorious prison in El Salvador where, you know, Trump is sending a lot of these migrants. So he was not sent back to his country of origin, which was Venezuela. And the Department of Homeland Security has claimed that he was affiliated with gangs and that they had reason to deport him. But again, all of this
拐上了大使桥，并被列入了驱逐出境名单。然后，你知道，几个月后，他的家人一直没有他的消息。他基本上从政府记录中被驱逐的移民名单中消失了。所以有一段时间他似乎被美国政府“人间蒸发”了。人们根本不知道他在哪里。从那以后，有报道表明他被送到了塞科特（Seekot），这是萨尔瓦多一个声名狼藉的监狱，你知道，特朗普正在把许多这样的移民送到那里。所以他没有被送回他的原籍国委内瑞拉。国土安全部声称他与帮派有联系，他们有理由将他驱逐出境。但同样，这一切
happened because he drove on to the ambassador by accident. Right. I mean, I mean, it's not the bridge's fault that the government has taken these sort of horrific actions against the people who crossed the border by accident. But the way I see the world is that bad design can tributes to horrible decisions and everything gets more complicated and it adds to the bridge's complicated legacy. Yeah, totally. I mean, this to me feels like one more kind of unfortunate chapter in the history of this giant piece of infrastructure that has been managed in these very specific ways over the years and how it's sort of formed this chokehold on the livelihoods of everybody who lives around it and relies on it because this bridge has been the only game
发生都是因为他开车不小心上了大使桥。对。我的意思是，政府对不小心过境的人采取了这种可怕的行动，这不是大桥的错。但据我看来，糟糕的设计会导致可怕的决定，一切都变得更加复杂，这也增加了大桥复杂的历史遗产。是的，完全是这样。对我来说，这感觉像是这件庞大基础设施历史上的又一个不幸篇章，多年来它一直以这些非常具体的方式被管理，以及它如何在某种程度上对周围生活和依赖它的人们的生计造成了扼杀，因为这座桥一直是唯一的选择。
in town. It took so much work just to get these highways to link up with the bridge, and then it took so much work recently to improve the signage that there's a big Canadian flag on it for people who may not read English or may not be able to decipher the sign quickly enough. But all of this stuff just adds to this stew of reasons why it's probably not in the best interest of the public to rely so much on the owners of this one bridge. You know, you may have heard about this other instance, these protests in 2022 where these like Canadian truckers literally blocked the bridge for several days because they were protesting COVID vaccine mandates, like nobody could get through. This was like a six-day protest. And over those six days, $300 million was lost because the auto industry
光是让这些高速公路与大桥连接起来就花了那么多功夫，最近为了改进标牌又花了那么多功夫，上面甚至有一个巨大的加拿大标志，以便那些可能看不懂英文或无法足够快地解读标牌的人辨认。但所有这些都加剧了公众不宜过分依赖这座桥的桥主的各种原因。你知道，你可能听说过另一件事，2022年的这些抗议活动，当时这些加拿大卡车司机因为抗议新冠疫苗强制令，直接把桥封锁了好几天，谁也过不去。这是一场为期六天的抗议活动。在这六天里，由于汽车行业
and all these other businesses that relied on the bridge just had literally no way to get their product across the bridge. So it helps explain why Canada was so desperate. it to get another bridge in place here and why so many people are fed up with the fact that this one bridge has been the only economic through line between these two extremely valuable nations. Well, it's really sobering stuff, and it's such a fascinating story. I'm so happy that you reported it for us. I mean, I just enjoyed the process of watching the story develop so much.
和所有其他依赖这座桥的企业简直无法将他们的产品运过桥，损失了3亿美元。这就解释了为什么加拿大如此迫切地想在这里建另一座桥，以及为什么这么多人对这座唯一的经济大动脉作为这两个极有价值国家之间唯一经济通道的现状感到厌倦。好吧，这真的很让人清醒，而且这是一个非常引人入胜的故事。我很高兴你为我们做了这篇报道。我的意思是，我真的很享受看着这个故事发展的过程。
So thank you for reporting it. I appreciate it. Thank you so much. It's been a real treat to dive into this. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Andrew Lapin. Andrew made a podcast called Radioactive about Detroit's inflammatory radio priest, Father Charles Coughlin, and you can check it out at Andrew Lapin.org. Editing this week by Chris Perube, fact-checking by Graham Hesha,
所以谢谢你的报道。我很感激。非常感谢。深入研究这个课题真是一种享受。《99%隐形》本周由安德鲁·拉宾（Andrew Lapin）制作。安德鲁制作了一个名为《放射性》（Radioactive）的播客，讲述底特律煽动性广播神父查尔斯·科夫林（Father Charles Coughlin）的故事，你可以在 Andrew Lapin.org 上查看。本周的剪辑由克里斯·佩鲁韦（Chris Perube）完成，事实核查由格雷姆·海沙（Graham Hesha）完成，
mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. Special thanks this week to Thomas Klug, Ray Lazarno, Glenn Lapin, and Anna Megdale, and the archival staffs at the Burton Historical Collection at the Detroit Public Library, and the Bentley Library at the University of Michigan for help with research. Recording help this week from Peg Watson at Michigan Public and Eric Wazon at Solid Sound. Our executive producer is Kathy, too. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall. Kurt Colstead is the digital director.
混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）完成，音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）创作。本周特别感谢托马斯·克卢格（Thomas Klug）、雷·拉扎诺（Ray Lazarno）、格伦·拉宾（Glenn Lapin）和安娜·梅格代尔（Anna Megdale），以及底特律公共图书馆伯顿历史档案馆和密歇根大学本特利图书馆的档案工作人员对研究的帮助。本周的录音帮助来自密歇根公共广播电台的佩格·沃森（Peg Watson）和坚实之声（Solid Sound）的埃里克·瓦松（Eric Wazon）。我们的执行制片人是凯茜·图（Kathy Tu）。我们的高级编辑是德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）。库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。
The rise of the team includes Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashamadon, Jacob Medina Gleason, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building. And beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on blue sky as well as our own Discord server. You can find all of our past episodes at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
团队成员包括杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、维维安·莱（Vivian Lay）、拉夏马顿（Lashamadon）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森（Jacob Medina Gleason）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）和我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于北边六个街区外的潘多拉大楼。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。你可以在蓝天（Blue Sky）以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到我们过去所有的节目。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。